i mean i'm sure obviously having a
record as big as this you probably had
crazy leverage with the label situation
what made you want to actually do the
major label things you really probably
didn't need to like what made you
actually do that
there was just certain things from them
that i wanted and it was just that's why
it's a joint venture it was just there
was just certain things that i like by
the way off of one record not a lot of
people are getting joint ventures
it doesn't work very rarely
if ever
but i mean
you know what come with a lot once you
hear some of the other stuff like when
you hear the follow-up i'm telling you
guys like it's it's dope but it's just
the intro just to just a taste
word
and i gave a little preview kind of of
what you're about to hear because you've
heard a little bit a lot of people's
favorite part of dallas is the little
three bars where i'm wrapping i snuck it
in there i feel like she just sleeps
she's gonna be a lot more rapping
not a lot but you know saying when i
feel like it now people understand that
i can tap in when i feel like that man
that's dope i mean because you can kind
of just
do what you could do you could do your
own hugs and then wrap the verses
or wrap the hook and sing the verses we
could do whatever and i feel like we're
kind of breaking all the rules now like
hey man like you said earlier and i
think that the last few years has proved
this
there is zero rules to what makes a hit
record anymore absolutely like zero